normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
Argentina elects anarco capitalist
Javier mle president today Begins the
end of Argentina's decline said The
Economist during his victory speech and
I think I have a a video for you that
we're going to play so you can
understand who this guy is I hope you
speak Spanish cuz here we go
Min okay he said Ministry of culture
out
treasury
out gender and diversity
[Laughter]
out I mean mayor Adams is about to do
this in New York City but just not not
on not cuz he wants to they just have
crazy budget they're closed libraries on
weekends now was complaining about it
that's now hold on now hear me out this
could be like a Libertarian Paradise
okaya no in New York City New York City
the cops are destroyed you can't do
anything about it all right and if you
here's what happens first it's uh uh
it's it's a stable liberal neoliberal
state so there's a bunch of laws
then things start breaking down and you
get anarco tyranny but after anarco
tyranny you get the collapse of
government institutions you get Anarchy
yeah the problem is you can't have guns
no no no no no that's anarco tyranny
like the cops will be like well this Law
Abiding Citizen is going to prison but
once the Anarchy phase happens and
there's no cops anymore been abolished
now you can do whatever you want I do
not want to live in New York City when
you do whatever you want so so here you
are now Argentina Alex Javier mle this
is a guy who's roasted the left he's
called him over and over again just like
you swear in different language cuz most
people don't know what you're saying but
uh some people are saying as brexit s uh
signaled the victory of Donald Trump in
the next election United States this
right here this is a landslide victory
for an anti-woke anarcho capitalist yeah
a lot of people are like it Trump's
going to win there's there's something
that people need to recall or think
about when it comes to this guy like
Argentina has like
150% inflation or something like that so
the prices have tripled since 2020 yeah
comparing Argentina I think that's what
I saw is the no but I mean like yeah
what do you think's going out with the
average average person it's not it's not
150% we're talking about like the i m to
New York City it was dollar sliced pizza
now it's $150 Pizza there's no dollar
Slice Pizza in New York and also this
has been this has been going on in
Argentina for multiple years too like
and it was going on long before like our
our inflation kicked in in the past you
know two years it's been going on in and
and the only reason I'm saying this is
because libertarian ideas as much as I
like them the average person is not at
the point where they're like screw the
whole government yet so the the American
the American population and I and again
you're talking to a guy that loves the
idea of cutting the government as much
as possible I'm just trying toal Trump
is winning among 18 to 34y olds I mean
he's not badly losing in New York right
now which is crazy cuz he should smoked
nor New York is D plus 27 and Biden's
winning by 10 yeah that's insane insane
yeah insane and the poll oversampled 2
to one Democrats it should be way higher
higher I 100% like everything you're
saying I just want I want people that in
America to to remember to to at least
remember that Argentina's conditions and
the United States conditions are
significantly different kind of reminds
me of s is uh you know how when when
Elon bought Twitter and then he fired
2third of everyone who went there and
everyone goes I wonder how this is going
to work out because if he can fire
2third of everybody why can't Facebook
go fire and YouTube and all the stuff so
like I wonder if this is going to kind
of be like a bit of a test run where he
goes you know what we don't need a
cultural diversity committee definit
whatever and he was going to scrap it
and he'll probably be like look it's
fine I I'm I went to the grocery store
the other night and uh we like to buy
these these little salamis I don't know
if you guys have seen we have in the
basement where it's like three different
kinds and there's maybe like 20 slices
of each it was $12 for a pack yeah dude
a year and a a year or so ago it was
like 750 oh yeah and so when we were
ringing them up my girlfriend's like
this is $12 and I'm like whoa oh yeah
that's crazy dude I mean yeah I go up
for to eat in New York and a lot of
times you know like you'll go on uh
Google Maps or whatever and then they'll
have the menu on there and a lot of
times the menu that they'll have have on
in Google Maps will be like 2 years old
and then you go in there and you see the
difference from 2 years ago and you go
wow like literally and it's never going
back dude like like a Taco Taco Bell is
like what what is it like three bucks an
hour or something yeah no no no like a
gordita crunch or whatever is like 350
yeah what was it a MCD double is
$3 be a dollar in in a couple years
you'll have the $5 menu for the stuff
that used to be the dollar menu the key
thing is it's like certain like for
Commodities Commodities are competitive
and they will probably but like for
prices at a restaurant and stuff like
they're not it's the grocer it's not
going back like eggs could maybe come
down or whatever but like restaurants
they don't lower prices I'll tell you
this I went to the grocery store and uh
I like me some heavy whipping cream in
my coffee yeah they didn't have it and
consistently now over the past year the
grocery store has not been carrying
heavy cream and when they do we grab
some and then it's gone for a few months
so we have to go to other places we have
to go to local farms or one of the
specialty organ shops to get like the
organic farm cream but a couple of our
local grocery stores typically don't
carry it all that often now I'll tell
you I'll tell you my theory yeah I'm
wondering if the margin profit margin
for derivative products is higher than
for the the pure product meaning if if
the if the company says we can sell a
pint uh uh or you know whatever little
little carton a pint of heavy cream and
we'll make $1 per per carton or whatever
if we take that same amount of cream and
sell it to people who are going to make
whipped cream or butter we might make $2
per pint because of the derivatives I'm
wondering if that's why the production
has gone down and the stores aren't
carrying it as much very possibly I mean
shrink flation is also crazy right now
truth social filed a defamation lawsuit
against 20 media companies this is
breaking in the past 10 minutes 10
minutes 10 minutes ago disclosed please
don't be Tim cast please don't be Tim
cast please don't be
Tim well we'll pull that up in the next
one we'll wrap this one up and we'll
pull that one up in a second so yeah
Javier is uh I mean it's in my opinion
it's great I love the idea of of giving
uh anarcho capitalist or you don't live
there let's just let it ride man I mean
the thing is I think that they're going
to they're going to work you know at
least in the short term because the
conditions that they've set up in the
past in Argentina everyone is everything
is is so all the money that they they
have is going straight to government and
government industry debt servicing as
costs are like I'm sure they're going to
have to they're going to they've they've
gone like I think they've they've
they've had like three times they've had
to restructure their debt so they'll
have to do it again because they have to
get dollars to Peg their by way the fact
that the United States did not re like
re service their Deb like two years ago
or whatever a low insane I don't I don't
even I don't even want to talk about it
because there's nothing that can be done
and when when interest rates were dir
zero and they're like people were like
why don't you ref and that was also when
Trump was like hey we should refill the
Strategic petroleum thing when gas was
like or yeah and everybody was like well
the fact that you're suggesting it means
we shouldn't so yeah so yeah I mean that
is a frustrating turn of events that
when things were cheap and and and good
we it seemed like obviously in hindsight
it seems so obvious you go interest
rates couldn't be lower possibly I guess
I guess the problem was Trump one moment
tried to be like maybe we should take
these bad boys
negative I don't know I I can't I can't
speak that I don't know at all so this
Malay guy I thought at first he made me
nervous cuz he was screaming about and
he was angry and screaming I'm like H
that sounds like Hitler but then I gave
him a chance I was like let's hear this
you know where Hitler lives right now uh
is he in Belgium he AR in Argentina he
was he
bar um but then I started watching him
and I I really really liked his
personality M's personality and also I
didn't know but he wants to take
Argentina off the peso and put him on
the US dollar well they're going to Peg
the peso to the doar I imagine the CIA
is behind this guy now and that's
probably why he won I don't know man CIA
was was likely behind uh Lula in Brazil
and that didn't work out great I don't
think the CIA would be behind a guy like
this I think the CIA would be opposed to
a guy like this because nowadays the the
the the federal government and the P
like the you know the narrative that is
pushed is not a right-wing small
government narrative it's definitely a
big government I thought the powers that
be the authoritarian powers that be
would not want him in power because he's
a populist libertarian but then the
people are like well but the liberal
economic order needs all the help it can
get so if Argentina wants to join as a
as a partner by taking the US Dollar on
then maybe it's worth it because this
whole crypto like economy thing is is
very Pro it's it's promising it's better
than just sucking it in and being like
well in 10 years my car is going to cost
$350,000 oh well that's not sustainable
so like and it just can't get much much
worse for them like they're just
obviously at a point where enough people
are like you know what it just this guy
cannot screw it up worse than it already
has been screwed up thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net